My mom is fighting stage 4 colorectal cancer, but she also has Hashimoto's.
You want to stimulate the immune system in someone with an autoimmune disorder.
Does this change what types of supplements to use for her cancer?
What a great question.
Boy, you guys are smart.
The answer is yes, it does and know what doesn't.
So it depends on the autoimmune disease that that person has.
So if it's Hashimoto's and they have breast cancer and you want to stimulate this person's immune system to kill the breast cancer cells, how are you going to balance this out?
Well, to me, you know, cancer trumps the autoimmune disease in this case because, you know, we're not going to die of Hashimoto's but we could die of breast cancer.
So we have to balance that out and that's where you have to treat the person with some wisdom.
However, there's lots of things you could do from an immune standpoint by using key reg stimulants.
So for instance, medicinal mushrooms are immune stimulants for people who have a suppressed immune system, but they aren't going to be hyper stimulants for people who have an autoimmune disease.
Typically, everybody's a little bit different with this, but typically a person with Hashimoto's can take medicinal mushrooms and not have any uptake of damage to their thyroid gland.
So there's ways to do it.
Plus you don't always kill cancer with just stimulating immune system production.
So back, step back a little bit, does a person have cancer because they have a suppressed immune system?
Many times, no, so it's not a suppressed immune system that is always causing cancer.
Now, can that be the case? Yes, do we have to use some immune booster sometimes? Yes, do we always? No, we don't.
When a person has cancer that cancer is in a state of high oxidative stress, those cancer cells that are replicated are replicated healthy cells, not healthy mitochondria.
They're not producing glutathione like they should. They're near the lethal dose of oxidative stress in the cell.
So one of the major ways that we use to help kill cancer is, well, first of all, we use rife technology, which is not immune stimulated at all.
It's killing the cancer directly and stimulating an immune attack on the cancer and giving it that tip over a fact of the oxidative stress to the cancer cell.
The way chemotherapy works to club cancer is creating more oxidative stress in the body that's going to create more oxidative stress in the cancer cell, tip it over to its lethal dose and kill the cancer cell.
That's how chemotherapy literally works. Well, we do that a lot with a lot of the cancer nutrients.
So you use higher dose vitamin C, even a liposomal vitamin C, certainly an IV vitamin C, use a lateral type B-17, use a protocell, there's many of the therapies that we use that are not immune stimulated per se, they're oxidative.
So they're created greater amount of oxidative stress in the cancer cell and thereby tipping it over its lethal dose and killing the cancer that way.
So you don't always have to, you have to be careful, you have to be more careful treating a cancer patient when the cancer patient also has a concurrent autoimmune disease.
Now there's certain autoimmune diseases that are more serious with that.
If a person has auto antibodies to myelin cheese cells, which we see commonly these days, then you really have to be careful stimulating the immune response because you're, you know, if I do that, you're creating a demilinated disease, which is very serious.
So it's yeah, there is different ways that you treat it with knowing that the person has a comorbidity of an autoimmune disease that's completely unrelated to the cancer.
So great question.